the Dominican Republic having kinky or
coarse hair is perceived as something
not unclean and temp something that is
simply not beautiful the salon really
cares about the way that premier is
perceived in society and we want to be a
part of that change fully in 2014 we
were trying to go into this bar and the
bouncer sent to my face you can't come
in because of your hair this hair has
done nothing to no one
this hair is part of who I am why should
I put this hair away and there knows
miss Teresa which means miss curls in
English and I am the owner of Miss
Teresa salon in the Dominican Republic
we offer all different types of services
specifically for naturally curly afro
textured hair in 2010 I remember just
straighten the heck out of my hair as my
curly hair would grow in and just touch
my hair feel the curl patterns and say
like what if all of my hair would feel
this way none that's when I decided that
it was time to look in the mirror and to
love myself fully
some of the things I was here back then
is like did you forget your comb at home
did you put your fingers on a socket I
mean all sorts of really neat things but
I had all these women to stop me and ask
me how to curl it how I do it where did
I cut it there was this huge thirst and
hunger for space where women would be
validated and then that led to this
space that I'm in now it's been the most
amazing activism I've done all my life
the things that with a brush a pic or a
comb I can empower someone
[Music]